il y a quand même 500000 téléspectateurs
de plus
crever ces quatre pneus et sa gueule
[Applaudissements]
je te jure c'est ma thématique c'est pas
moi c'est des maths c'est pas moi
5 minutes juste 5 minutes laissez-le
fermer ta question
tu peux poser ma question chère Mathieu
ça commence mal regarde-moi Mathieu tu
as connu beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle traumatisantes durant ta
carrière est-ce que ouf était la pire de
toutes
mais tes lunettes je
n'ai pas la star d'énergie 12 ma voiture
est à côté de bots de crew j'étais le
number one dans la chaîne j'étais à
Canal j'ai 20 ans de quotidienne où
j'étais là tous les soirs j'ai 80 % de
ton notoriété je fais 800000 de TPMP
people qu'est-ce que vous m'emmerdez
[Applaudissements]
là tu as tapé fort excusez-moi pour
cette démonstration de force commence
sur les pieds
partout comme ça avec tous les chaînes
qui nous a balancé
86 ans
passion et tu as plus longtemps attendre
10 15 ans
[Rires]
et vraiment m'adresse plus la parole
regardez qu'est-ce qu'on s'en branle sur
Disney que ça va te remettre en scène
il est sauvé par un truc c'est son âge
ils ont plus tard
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il est rédacteur en chef
dans 10 jours il bosse ailleurs je te le
dis
un peu de chance il est très doué
et quand à toi pardon je te le dis tu es
un beau bâtard
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur de rien moi les gars là tu
appelles au Canada je suis un peu
partout
au Canada c'est pour ça la télé
[Rires]
la dernière fois est-ce que tu peux
est-ce que tu peux devoir la prendre
est-ce que tu peux devant la France
prendre une sanction pour Théo bien sûr
Théo c'est la dernière fois que ça se
reproduise
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention Théo tout le monde alors alors
ils sont en train de me dire ils sont en
train de me dire et c'est pas de leur
faute ils ont un énorme bug dans le
système ils essaient de régler ça
on a été piraté
sur le truc sur la machine
malheureusement dans la machine c'est
parfois les hommes sont battus par les
machines
[Rires]
c'est un bug informatique
[Applaudissements]
ça bug informatique tu es au dessus de
ça
je te jure sur ce que j'ai de plus cher
c'est quoi
ma voiture
encore une petite blague de Théo
Marseille et ses petits copains
là encore une blague je quitte le
plateau évidemment j'ai ma pige voilà
des spectateurs comprendront et je
reviens quand j'aurai envie de revenir
et après des excuses publiques
mais de toi pas de ma mère
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis le seul truc qui aura pas
c'est sûr c'est la pige
voilà pourquoi
c'est une règle de trois c'est un
Matthieu est arrivé un truc x = le temps
de passage non pas non ah non ah non 600